for the second night in a row locals
came together to show
support for cubans who are thousands of
miles away thanks for joining us at 11
i'm denise faldis and i'm brian loftis
dozens traveling across the valley to
the federal courthouse downtown with
chants
flags and a message of unity sasha
loftis joining us live near las vegas
boulevard and clark with more
on tonight's movement sasha
ryan that movement is continuing nearly
five
hours after it started you can see a
large group
still here across from the federal
courthouse courthouse downtown
many we spoke with tonight have family
and friends in cuba they say
those they love are suffering and
they're holding these demonstrations to
stand by them
chance cries and pleas for change
carry across the streets of las vegas we
need
all the support possible as dozens stand
with those suffering
more than 2400 miles away the cuban
people
are dying the cuban people are hungry
wednesday's demonstration marked the
latest of many
here in the valley and all around the
world all to support
the people of cuba we are sick and tired
of having 62 years of communism
and brutal dictatorship inside of our
island
thousands of cubans are calling for an
end to the country's
62-year communist regime
they're taking to the streets for the
first time in decades
citing deteriorating living conditions
food shortages
and price hikes only made worse by the
covet 19
crisis we need some help because our
people cannot do it by themselves
those here are asking the united states
government for help
and they want us all to understand when
you tell people here
how live is in cuba they don't believe
you they're fighting for those they love
and the freedom they so desperately
deserve
you know it's either now or never
now back out here live just a few hours
ago reports surfaced of the cuban
government temporarily lifting
restrictions on the food or medicine
travelers can bring
as an apparent concession to demands but
protests are still happening
all across the country now here in las
vegas those impassioned pleas
continue this group is set to hold
another demonstration coming up
this friday night of course stay with
eight news now for the latest coverage
reporting live downtown tonight sasha
loftis 8 news now